Andriana gathered data on different
schools winning percentages and the
average yearly salary of their head
coaches and millions of dollars in the
years 2000 to 2011 she then created the
following scatter plot and trend line so
this is salary and millions of dollars
in the winning percentage and so here we
have a coach who made over four million
dollars and it looks like they won over
eighty percent of their games then you
have this coach over here who has a
salary of a little over a million and a
half dollars and they are winning over
85 percent and so each of one of these
data points is a coach and it's plotting
their salary or their winning percentage
against their salary assuming the line
correctly shows the trend in the data
and it's a bit of an assumption there
are some outliers here that are well
away from the model and this isn't it it
looks like there's a linear a positive
linear correlation here but it's not
super tight and there's a bunch of
coaches right over here in the lower
salary area going all the way from
20-something percent to over 60 percent
assuming the line correctly shows the
trend in the data what does it mean that
the lies y-intercept is 39 well if you
believe the model and the flu then a
y-intercept of being 39 would be the
model is saying that if someone makes no
money that they could with zero dollars
that they could win that the model would
expect them to win 39 percent of their
games which seems a little unrealistic
because you would expect most coaches to
get paid something but anyway let's see
which of these choices actually describe
that so that me look at the choices the
average salary was 39 million dollars no
no one on our chart made 39 million on
average each million dollar increase in
salary was associated with a 39 percent
increase in winning percentage of that
that would be something related to the
slope and the slope was definitely not
39 the average winning percentage was
39% no that wasn't the case either the
model indicates that teams with coaches
who had a salary of 0 million dollars
will average a winning percentage of
approximately 39 percent yeah this is
the closest statement to what we just
said
if you believe that model and that's a
big if if you believe this model then
this model says someone making zero
dollars will get 39% and this is frankly
why you have to be skeptical of models
they're not going to be perfect
especially at extreme cases oftentimes
but who knows anyway hopefully you found
that useful